hacemos
[Música]
hola a todos y bienvenidos a los
observadores de france 24 comenzamos a
esta semana de mi alma donde mujeres y
hombres se oponen al golpe de
estado-militar desde el primero de
febrero pero la represión se ha
intensificado y los manifestantes han
encontrado nuevas técnicas pacíficas
para expresar su desaprobación
[Música]
jamás
una mujer mayor se enfrenta a un grupo
de soldados es una de las ciudadanas de
mianmar que ha desafiado abiertamente al
ejército durante las manifestaciones
contra el golpe militar desde el primero
de febrero
ojos ojo me hablan de ayer
aute pero enfrentarse directamente las
autoridades implica riesgos
las fuerzas del orden dispararon
munición real contra la multitud para
evitar altercados violentos con la
policía los manifestantes están luchando
de forma creativa para desarrollar
nuevas formas de desobediencia civil
dijimos que nuestro motor se averió
estacionamos en la carretera principal y
cuando la policía viene y nos pide que
nos vayamos decimos yo no estoy parado
espero que no
la gente se amarra los cordones de los
zapatos en medio de la calle
además algunas personas cruzan la calle
una y otra vez
dan vueltas en círculos en las
intersecciones
la policía no puede hacer nada porque
solo están cruzando la calle
pacíficamente
mi técnica favorita es cuando la gente
finge que se le caen las verduras
tienen una gran bolsa de cebollas o a
veces arroz alguien la deja caer al
suelo y todo se desparrama en la calle
mucha gente intenta entonces ayudarle a
reposar las cosas pero en realidad crean
aún más desorden táctica que golpean a
meter todo en la bolsa pero hay un hueco
en el fondo por lo que todo se vuelve a
caer y es bueno ser valiente no dejarse
intimidar por los soldados las armas los
tanques pero también debemos protegernos
a nosotros mismos
tenemos que estar seguros creemos que
esta es la única manera de resistir al
golpe militar con seguridad y eficacia
si la oposición al golpe de estado ni al
mar es real dos imágenes falsas
circularon el inicio de la movilización
las vamos a ver en este episodio de info
en tops que podrá encontrar en nuestra
cuenta de instagram hombres y mujeres
muestran su oposición al golpe de estado
cartelería mar si no luchan acabarán
como los tailandeses sin futuro
desde el golpe militar del primero de
febrero y me amarán circulado varias
fotos falsas algunas para desacreditar a
los manifestantes otras para agitar a la
opinión pública por ejemplo esta foto de
la ex jefa del ejecutivo ozone switch y
que supuestamente fue tomada en el
momento de su detención por parte del
ejército para saber de dónde proviene
esta foto basta con hacer una búsqueda
inversa de imágenes por ejemplo en
google imágenes y allí descubrimos que
esta foto es de una película del
director francés luc bessón incluso se
puede encontrar el extracto del tráiler
de dónde proviene esta foto
[Música]
segundo ejemplo compartido 1300 veces en
facebook un internauta afirma que los
médicos de mi amar ha comparado su
situación con la de tailandia en ese
país vecino de mianmar los manifestantes
prodemocracia llevan meses pidiendo sin
éxito que se reforme la monarquía pero
también en este caso como demostró la
agencia france presse factual una
búsqueda inversa de imágenes muestra que
este cartel es falso en la foto real se
puede leer una frase más sencilla en
birmano nos oponemos al golpe de estado
militar contra el pueblo
estas dos fotos son un recordatorio de
que cualquier acontecimiento
internacional puede dar lugar a la
difusión de imágenes falsas así que
siempre que tengan dudas piensen en
hacer una búsqueda inversa de imágenes
en segundos pueden evitar transmitir una
noticia falsa
terminamos esta semana en benin donde
nuestro observador hace sonar la alarma
para salvar un patrimonio arquitectónico
típico de su ciudad por tono el segundo
piso
como pueden verlo estos son los primeros
daños los primeros daños
la persona que graba se llama ya o al y
es beninés y muestra las ruinas de la
villa flora si leña construida por su
bisabuelo hace más de 100 años estas
casas fueron construidas por
descendientes de esclavos liberados en
brasil al volver a venir trajeron
consigo las técnicas arquitectónicas de
sus amos en el siglo 19 construir este
tipo de edificios era un signo de
riqueza pero hoy en día la mayoría se
encuentran en un avanzado estado de
deterioro según nuestro observador
para mí estas casas están amenazadas por
la falta de mantenimiento por el
abandono la mayoría de los herederos con
el tiempo abandonan las casas porque
fundan sus hogares muchas partes de
estas casas están destruidas
no hay techos en estas casas no hay
ventanas las paredes están agrietadas es
un espectáculo que no le hace honor a la
ciudad de portonovo
[Música]
en portonovo el ayuntamiento afirma su
voluntad de salvaguardar el patrimonio y
recientemente renovó tres villas pero
para asia vale esto no es suficiente
tres o cuatro casas al lado de un
centenar no es casi nada
yo creo que tendrán que hacer mucho más
esfuerzo me gustaría hacer un llamado a
las autoridades que deben ocuparse mucho
más de la cuestión de la protección de
los edificios afrobrasileños son
testigos vivos de la historia de la
historia de la trata de esclavos de la
historia de áfrica así que no debemos
dejarlos morir
si ustedes también quieren contarnos lo
que pasa a su alrededor todos nuestros
contactos aparecen en pantalla envíenos
sus fotos y videos aficionados y tal vez
uno de ustedes podrá ser nuestro próximo
observador de france 24 hasta pronto
[Música]